what's up guys
bang bang it is lunch money time i am
here with polina she looks like an angel
as
usual don't forget that lunch money is
now sponsored by
block fi go to block fight.com and get
an account today you can earn up to 8.6
apy in an interest bearing account and
also
you can sign up for the waitlist for the
credit card that pays you in bitcoin
rather than cashback airline miles a
bitcoin rewards credit card no brainer
go to blockbuy.com
blockfy.com what's up we're we're under
the pressure under the gun
we got some nice lights today
all right first topic time magazine
plans to lean into surging demand for
digital currency
and art currently two of the hottest
trends in the global economy
time has designed its first ever cover
exclusively as an
nft non-fungible token featuring the
bold title
is fiat dead it's a nod to one of its
most iconic cover designs from 1966
is god dead and april 3rd 2017 is
truth dead what do we think
anthony was instrumental in this fun
fact i don't know if that's instrumental
you were instrumental i had a little
little input
uh this is a no-brainer for me if you
have intellectual property you should
absolutely sell it there's no difference
between taking the intellectual property
and printing it on a t-shirt
a poster a physical piece of paper or in
a digital file and now that you can do
it in a digital file what we're going to
find is intellectual property which
drastically undervalued around the world
time uh covers are a great example of
something that previously people would
have thought was like a five dollar
thing
now they're going for thousands of
thousands of dollars
people have time covers as art on their
walls and their home
so
microsoft is in talk to acquire and
talks to acquire
discord a video game chat community for
more than 10
billion dollars 10 billion with a b
undervalued what undervalued
should absolutely be way higher if uh
satya nadal nadal nadella
uh pulls this off uh oh gee
absolutely but one source according to
the bloomberg article says
that discord is more likely to go public
than sell itself we'll see
10 billion is a lot of money people are
underestimating they sleeping on how big
discord is
massive next lockheed martin is
partnering with a satellite startup
called omnispace
to build a space based 5g network
why everybody try to compete with elon
musk
everybody trying to compete my boy elon
musk are you going to do that
everybody try to compete with elon
musk spacex bang bang star link
eventually they'll spin it out they'll
take it public is my guess
it's gonna be a winner chicken chicken
dinner next all right hold on
oh god we work we work
we work we work disclosed a
3.2 billion dollar loss in 2020
as it seeks a spac deal
wow wow damn it's actually getting
better 5 billion is so bad no no no
it lost 3.5 billion loss in 2019
and in 2020 they only lost 3.2 billion
oh my god so it actually got
better they improved and to be fair
to have improved uh about 10 percent
their losses in a year where people were
abandoning
uh office space left and right would you
do a smack with a company that lost 3.5
billion and then 3.2 billion two years
in a row
well it depends on what it looks like
they're going to do in 2021
maybe they're going to be profitable as
people come back into their offices you
have no clue
i do have a clue it's really hard to
close a gap that's 3.2
billion dollars wide
ready drone footage gets incredibly
close to an
icelandic volcano eruption oh my god
this was sick it has it it marks the
first time the volcano has erupted in
800 years what are these people
doing so closely volcano watching oh my
god okay wait guys we went to iceland
once and we did this
um thing where we went to a volcano and
the woman who was taking the picture was
like get closer and get closer to the
crack in the earth where if you fall
you literally will die forever and we
were so close anything was like i'm i'm
not getting any closer to that
i don't mess with you close i don't mess
with the crust of the earth i respect it
all listen
me and nature we're boys we get along
great we
got no problems it's ask lunch money 10
ask lm in the comments below question
from
lily c hi lily hi pompeo paulina when
will you be releasing lunch money the
profile and pump motors merchandise
would love to support the series by
buying a hoodie
t-shirt mug or stickers lily you're the
best
motors do not give my mom and dad ideas
they still are getting phone calls from
when i wore a shirt on here one time
that time you got to wear this shirt
again you got to wear this shirt again
we'll see what we'll work on uh
i would love to do profile merch i
already have some but like
it's only like a few shirts well we need
to order some more for lilly
we'll work on it give me your size we'll
work on it all right um
moist day 27 so day 28 today
day 27 of commenting every day my
favorite rap song really depends on my
mood but a classic for me is very bonds
by kanye featuring lil wayne
the entire graduation album is one of my
fav who moist
you who how oh okay the entire
graduation album is one of my favorites
assuming i'm stranded on the island
too that i'm eating the big back big mac
myself
lol ah smart but if i'm playing god
between you two then i have to follow
protocol women and children first sorry
pop
wow winning points left and right also
you have a size advantage
and we'll be able to survive longer
without food that ain't true
i can survive anything i've survived 29
years in this size
i can survive anything moist advantage
twice just that we're clear there's a
typo in here
oh you tried to get cute you tried to be
a smart ass and now you have a typo
moist um that's not a typo no it's just
the doubling of the word
which is the typo typo is mystic
spelling
kanye west is pretty good but to be
honest
nwa biggie and jay-z are better facts
facts lil wayne for the record for those
that don't know lil wayne carter ii
first time i ever skipped school
was in high school i think i was a
sophomore or a junior and
probably a junior because we had to have
cars then and uh bam
they used to drop the albums on tuesday
cds in the store
we skipped school me and my friend never
forget cameron watts we sat out in the
parking lot
played fire fire fire man and we just
sat there all day we didn't even go
anywhere we literally skipped school by
sitting in the parking lot listening to
lil wayne
i skipped school once to read a book
loser
all right that's it today see ya bang
bang
hope you guys enjoyed this episode of
lunch money as much as we did
and don't forget lunch money is now
sponsored by block five so go check them
out there's a link in the description
that you can click
on i'm an investor a user and a huge fan
what you're a bigger fan of block five
than you are of me
block five is my second favorite thing
in the world behind paulina they've got
three
products they can give you a us dollar
loan you can earn up to eight point six
percent interest on an interest-bearing
account
or you can buy and sell cryptocurrencies
on their crypto exchange
i personally use the interest bearing
account there's not very many places
where you'll find up to 8.6
interest on a deposit in an interest
bearing account go do your own research
there's risk associated but 8.6
is pretty compelling so click on the
link in the description say thanks to
the folks at blockfly
subscribe to our channel like the video
annoy pulling in the comments
and we'll see you guys tomorrow and be
kind to your friends